where's your banjo
no it's guitar today get used to it niko
[Music]
welcome back to the podcast thank you
peter
we are back again
i am playing guitar instead of a banjo
i'm sorry but i don't really know how to
play banjo
so don't judge me if i only know guitar
i'm just playing saving yourself guys
[Music]
that's actually that's a jordan that's
that's a george strait song
with obviously different lyrics
hey what's up everybody welcome to the
podcast thanks for joining us
yeah um we are secretly big secret we
are secretly live right now
somewhere on corridor digital.com uh we
are testing
live so if you guys having to find this
anywhere uh
you just found an easter egg so
congratulations
um but uh so there may be
some jank there may be some things that
happen uh if you find us live
uh do not be worried
they'd be so excited it is all going
according to plan
um so all one or two viewers in there
they're like wait what
so today we got ren peter nico myself
how's it going hey guys hello and uh
i thought this would be a fun
opportunity to talk about um
not only what you guys were doing today
but also kind of
what that's spurring on in sort of a
learning journey i feel like 2020 was a
year of survival but 2021
is a year of improvement
innovation and learning and uh
i'm feeling that anyway so yeah i've
been playing guitar more
um and uh working on a few things
uh on corridor so sounds like you guys
were
getting deep into the weeds it sounded
like an intimate day today
oh by the way you want the microphone
pointed at your mouth every time
at least it's not backwards this time
anyway by the way you want the
microphone pointed at your mouth
okay on my mic at home it's like that
okay
i might get home it's like that okay
so it's like it's like jake's mic there
it's you know yeah i'll tell you
what i'm actually i'm gonna get a sure i
think eventually but anyway sure
yeah nico what's going on over there you
guys are naked
basically if you're listening to this an
audio only we are wearing clothes
actually but the digital forms are
ourselves who knows
uh so here's what they're doing on our
hard drives
so big picture we're kind of getting not
kind of we are getting into
unreal engine for filmmaking um the idea
of being able to do
animated stuff without like because you
have
animated movies and shows where it's
basically cartoon style key framing you
know whether or not it's cg
but we want to try to get into this
realm of doing animated stuff but
without
necessarily having to go through the
slog of having to do it all by hand
so we are experimenting with motion
capture
facial capture uh real-time filmmaking
all that good stuff
basically we're looking at the
puppeteering equivalent of making an
animated series
the really exciting thing is that every
video game level you can find on unreal
marketplace every character those are
all free locations now
or well maybe not free maybe 30 bucks
but they're locations that are
accessible as opposed to like well we
can't go shoot in the middle of
the u.s bank tower exactly since we had
a digital one then we could just
do it and that's the location that you
can switch halfway through your day you
don't have to pick up your whole
production and move there you just
load up a new project and yeah your uh
your your location fees are a lot less i
think
that's very true and looking at video
games like
take note of how much cinematics exist
in video games video games are really
just a vehicle to play you cinematics
with like
kind of just template video game
gameplay in between for the most part
i wouldn't say that
well you and i have uh this is jaded
nico coming out again
oh i'm so jaded about video games guys
i mean i've been gaming since i was a
baby
okay what's the last truly great video
game you've played population one
that's fast that's just vr fortnite man
hey but it is vr fortnite
is great this is true population one is
great
i don't know the last good single-player
game i've played
half-life alex i don't think i mean half
of alex was
good i didn't finish it but to be fair
also to riff-desk that was janking out
really hard when i was trying to play
um and yeah so
man what is the last good single-payer
game i've played
i don't know i've gotten really sucked
into multiplayer games but you know what
you guys are just distracting me you're
just getting me
off track my most recent
favorite single-player game is probably
horizon zero dawn i want to play that so
bad it's so good
i need to get a ps whatever it's been a
few years since i played i actually
started replaying it again
last fall and i don't know i played
maybe half of it before i
put it down and then never played it
again accidentally
do you guys ever have that where it's
like you're really enjoying a game and
then like you put it down one day
you know like it's the end of the night
you you know turn off your console
and then the next day when it's around
the same time to play video game again
you're like
i'm gonna try this other thing or do
something else instead then another day
goes by then
three days goes by then a month goes by
next thing you know you've never
touched the game ever again that's what
happened with f5 alex and myself
yeah but you know i think the biggest
headliner game that i tried that i was
pretty disappointed with was god of war
the newest one okay oh really
so i'm really critical about writing in
video games like
when they just do away with all the
things that you're supposed to do in a
story like get your attention and get
you invested in characters and they just
ignore that because it's a video game
it's like why you guys
you still have to do this stuff like i
have like why do these characters care
about each other you just
made them start caring about each other
you can't just it's cheap
that's easy so the game felt like
unmotivated and the character
yeah i mean like the the stuff between
like uh kratos and his son was
interesting
but like they didn't quite like they got
to a story eventually but they didn't
really
didn't quite hit that story ideally but
i actually found the gameplay to be
super boring
like it was just the most generic hack
and slash in my opinion like which was
really just a vehicle for graphics set
pieces
isn't it kind of like on rails too yeah
kinda
and like that doesn't do it for me
anymore like i i've never played god of
war but i've always kind of
seen it as like one of those games where
what do you call that game mechanic
where it's like
the button pops up and you're supposed
to hit it at the right time quick time
is it a game like that i kind of get
yeah but there's also like you know
fighting
sections but like the fighting sections
really are just made for people to mash
the attack i mean
some people reply like you need to play
on a hard difficulty and it's actually
really a challenge and you're probably
right
but for the most part it's just hit the
attack button and you'll win
because the game's made for mass
audiences you know yeah i really enjoyed
the
recent spider-man game and by recent i
mean the previously recent not the
my miles rallis game i haven't played
that one because i don't have a ps5 but
i know it's available on ps4 but i just
didn't get it that's one of those games
i've only played at my friend's houses
and so it has just a special place in my
heart you know
it's a very very good game man the
spider-man game is like finally like you
can
you know fly around new york city
swinging around the game play the the
fighting mechanics are pretty good in my
opinion
um yeah but whether you're looking at
god of war or cyberpunk 27
2077 or spider-man or any of these games
they all have a
ton of cinematics like not like just a
movie's length but like
five movies lengths worth of cinematics
like more than like a season of
television
and it's really high fidelity and it's
usually done really well and this is
kind of like the gaming industry going
like
guys guys it's really easy to make
cinematics in video games well you know
quote unquote really easy but
it's not as hard as you would think to
turn out content as long as the writing
is there because at the end of the day
you're just kind of doing theater
wearing a mocap suit
so that's what we're kind of jumping
into here and we're really excited about
it i think the thing that really brings
us together
is that ray tracing has been has become
a thing that you can do
in in games and ray tracing is when you
are
when you are basically doing the kind of
lighting that you would do
if you're doing a high-end cg animation
you know you're casting rays from the
camera you're casting rays from the
lights
you're bouncing them around the scene to
get your lighting calculations your
shadow calculations and reflection
calculations
and it's funny because when they first
announced they could do ray tracing on
these cars i was like
why would i want to lose 20 or 30 frames
per second just so i could get some
better reflections the game plays just
fine without it
it's like everybody's missing the point
is that jaded nico is that no that's not
me
i love ray tracing because i know what
it unlocks most people
don't understand that when you're
designing a video game you have to bake
the lighting you
like you can have some dynamic lighting
but when you put lights in a video game
it doesn't just light the scene and
that's it you continue you need to then
once you're done placing your lighting
and building your scene you need to then
quote unquote bake the lighting where
then the computer goes and it calculates
how the lights interact with all the
services how it's interacting the space
how you have
different bounces calculating the
shadows for everything that's not moving
that's going to remain static
and like and then once that's done it
basically puts that into a giant texture
so to speak
so that when you play the video game
your little old xbox
doesn't have to sit there and calculate
all the lighting the lighting's already
been pre-calculated
exactly so it's like you're really just
walking into a room
that is just completely like ambiently
lit there's not like any dynamic
lighting
but the lighting is built into the
actual photo texture of the scene so
it's like oh it's a little dark in that
corner it's because
if you're to open up the texture for
that corner it's dark in that corner
yep uh on in the actual like jpeg image
so the room has been
painted with light like a texture
painted with light
yes there's no actual lighting happening
this is interesting i didn't need it
but with ray trace because normally in
cg graphics that you don't do that you
know it's like
you have your texture and you're rather
you have your 3d model and all like the
the maps around it in normal bump
uh roughness specular etc etc right and
so it looks
a certain way it exists as a certain way
and then once you start putting the
lights in it reacts to those lights
naturally
uh so that's that gives you the control
to place lights wherever you want to
really like compose lighting on a scene
well we should mention why baked
lighting is it was a problem
sure so so because you know so i was
talking about all this baked lighting
but like what's the issue i might bring
that up well
baking your lighting takes sometimes
hours
to do um at the very least it's going to
take like five to ten minutes for like a
basic scene
you might be able to get down to like
one or two minutes if you have a really
fast computer
but let's say you're trying to do a
short film in a video game engine
like okay i got my camera here my
character's over there oh i need to move
this prop
i need to move this piece of scenery oh
i need to move a light
to light my character differently to
match the camera
time to bake the lighting i'll see you
guys in two hours i have an analogy for
that it's like imagine you're on a film
set
and like your gaffer sets up a light and
then welds it to the ground
and now and then he's like all right
time for the next setup you pull out
your freaking
angle grinder take it to the thing
so you know baking your lighting is fine
you know it's great for an actual video
game to make it run fast but when it
comes to filmmaking
it basically it's it's a star a stopper
a hard stopper to actually being able to
flow through the creative process it
really slows it down
so ray tracing lets you do away with all
of that
no more pre-computed lighting you can do
all of your lighting in real time you
can change your lights you can change
your colors change your light types
change your environment you can do all
of that
and everything's updating instantly it's
just you live in that world in real time
and that was not possible until like
literally the last year correct
and arguably the two series like the
2000 series of nvidia cards they could
do some retracing
not enough to really make you know full
dynamic lighting a real possibility
now with the the 3000 series plus you
know some more optima
optimizations were there and it's super
cool
i'm confused by nvidia's naming scheme
because for a long time it was like the
580 the 680 the 780 and then i guess
they skipped the 880 and then went
straight to the 9800
because they had the 8 800 series which
was like the big
card back in the day so they didn't want
to have like confused names
and then they were like 2000 series
one guy who does all the naming
conventions for big tech
yeah it's like xbox 360 and then not
xbox 720 xbox
one whoever is in charge of naming stuff
at microsoft should be
fired oh definitely you know what they
call it the xbox 360 the xbox 360 right
i do yeah because the playstation 3 was
coming out and they couldn't call the
xbox two because it sounds like it's a
generation behind the playstation 3.
they should have called the next box
but then what happens when the next next
box comes out next box squared the xbone
the xml so they also did that with
iphones when they went from eight to ten
yep yeah like they're just like uh
nine's gonna sound
let's just let's just skip a level
honestly if the iphone 9 did come out
i'd be like i'll just wait for the 10.
yeah but honestly i think the xbox 360
was a brilliant name and i think that
was the last time
microsoft had a good name because then
they went to the xbox one
and it's like okay that's not confusing
at all x there's the first xbox the xbox
one
and then there's the xbox one but it was
like wasn't that big of a deal and then
and then and then they had to go and
call it like the xbox one
can you imagine being like a 40 year old
mother trying to buy your
your son a christmas present and you're
like because there's the
last gen xbox series 40 year old
mother's only five years older than me
hey you could be a 40 year old mother i
know what dude
i was like original you did you're like
60 year old mother but my point is that
like but there there's the xbox one and
then they kept like
reducing its size making it cheaper and
then eventually it was like
i don't even know that names anymore but
there was like th the
old version of the xbox one that's new
the newest
old the newest last gen xbox has a very
similar naming
system to the new xbox and there's two
versions of the new one for there too
and it's like i i i cannot fault any
40-year-old mother going to gamestop and
then uh you know getting them stunks
uh no sorry i got super distracted there
he's like i got some stocks by my for my
son
and he told me to buy an xbox s 365.
look at microsoft office 365
what do i do does this plug into the
vista
it was like the home vista yeah as i
bought him
i bought a game boy advance instead
yeah oh boy but yeah you know but ray
trace lighting and all the ray tracing
that they added to the cards
what it really does is it also makes it
a lot easier for developers to
make a video game level without having
to sit there and bake the whole thing
either all the time like it
we are on the track to eliminating a
thing that takes hours and hours and
hours to do so
you know everybody's complaining about
ray tracing i feel like they're very i
mean obviously they don't know the ins
and outs of like the technical side of
these video game engines but it's
definitely a bit of a short-sighted
thing to complain about
because it is ushering in the next
generation of graphics and that next
generation of graphics
is what we're going to be playing with
when we do these unreal videos
yeah dude yeah i was a bit skeptical at
first of like using unreal for virtual
production i was like
that's just like doing cgi but it looks
worse you know
i was like i'm not that into this and
then i realized that you can use
it's you're making a movie in a game
engine
so you can employ all of the strategies
that games use
to have like crazy crowds and people
interacting with each other
air fights going on instead of animating
a tank driving through a scene
you just hop into the scene with your
controller and you just pilot it as if
you're playing a video game and then you
render that out it's a beautiful so
when you do that are you like actually
like recording keyframes when you drive
the tank through a scene and you're like
all right i'm gonna
drive forward a little bit and then have
the thing to look to the left and then
to the right and then drive forward
again and it's like yeah
it bakes out the key turns it into a
performance as opposed to an animation
that's where it's at
performing rather than animating even in
small little ways it's puppetry
yeah it really is puppetry at the end of
the day clint and i were talking about
uh a sequel to boss town too where uh
the robot's like in the woods
and so the little dog has uh and in our
video he doesn't have an arm
uh but in in real life that little dog
has like this arm that bends out and
we're like
we could totally just hook up like the
uh one of our motion capture suits with
the the hand tracking
and literally just like puppet that arm
on the dog and just like do all of this
stuff
but like do that way after the fact like
you do all this stuff on set and then
like
later you literally just all right i'm
doing the shot
yeah totally that's been something i've
been wanting to like play with
is using motion capture suits for
non-bipedal
motion capture it's like yeah a serpent
it's like there you go you got your
serpent right there
yeah or you did like that robotic
spatula yeah
which is insane in here it's just insane
he's a psychopath he just bought a vr
headset
and got into unreal so i'm very excited
about what a vr headset oh yeah you
convinced him to do that right right
i think i did an instagram dm you're
just gonna say
yeah so whatever he makes is like
courtesy of me basically it's basically
yours
yeah yeah at the end of his movie it's
just going to be like directed by peter
francis exactly
special thanks to peter francis based on
based on original concepts by peter
franz
based on the life of peter
and then produced by you know ian hubert
[Laughter]
so in our journey to do unreal uh movie
making
you know like with everything in
corridor we try to look for all the
tools that make it as easy and as fast
as possible
because people have been making video
games for a long time and so why the
heck do we want to sit there trying to
build the wheel all over again when
other people have made so many tools to
do so
well a lot of the tools are super janky
and not that well implemented
but recently we found character creator
i should say that sam has been looking
into character creator
so you know unreal announced their
metahuman which is basically a human
being
creator thing for unreal engine but it's
not actually out yet
and we need an easy way to make
characters for ourselves we don't have
to model it
and then rig it and then set everything
up
and name all the bones and set up with
milk and motion capture the idea you
know it's a
long process that really you do the same
every time you do it
so something like character creator just
does it all for you you just get to like
make your character it's basically the
character creation screen from like
skyrim
and you know what better way to
make corridor content than to turn
experiments into videos
so what we are currently doing is we are
making
uh all of ourselves into handsome
squidwards
you know the meme you know squidward you
know how he looks all
weird because he's handsome what if what
if you guys could do that to each other
yeah so the character creator has a
thing where you can take a picture of
yourself
and basically have it roughly make your
face it's not perfect but
it's pretty damn good it's pretty dang
good you look like a video game version
of yourself which is cool
but you can go in by hand and tweak it
and dial it in which we all did
and then you can take that and go like
all right time to go crazy with those
sliders
jaw max square brows maximum thickness
cheekbones maximum height
puffiness yep yeah
that's it's gonna be so weird it's
really
very weird also it's like because it
renders out the whole body
too
by default there are no clothes but also
there are no genitalia so it's like
it's like the titans from attack on
titan yeah it's like just
really weird and nico you and i are weak
this is like smooth
groin all day we're in the middle of a
segment so we didn't really get to
expand on it all but there's totally an
idea to do like an actual like
live-action attack on titan thing with
like real titans i feel like we should
maybe like maybe it's not like we're
flying around killing them but like
maybe it's just like
titan's in los angeles and it's just
yeah a quick fun render thing yeah yeah
yeah no totally
the scale of titans in real life i've
actually been thinking about that video
because it's like an attack on titan
like the the colossal titan oh
it literally looks like a skyscraper
yeah
it's like literally like towering over a
city but it's a 50 meter titan
that's 150 feet it's not that big it's
not big at all
it's like it's like barely taller than
like a
medium-sized apartment pretty tall
it's pretty tough 150 feet is very tall
but it's smaller than a spacex rocket
wow really yeah that's 230 feet they
fast and loose with the colossal titan
scale and the but yeah like the same
thing with like aaron
aaron's titan like i think he's like 15
meters that's like less than 50 feet
yeah and and uh you're like but they
always seem so huge and then you
actually see
uh like the buildings they're like
four-story buildings and he's like the
same height as them i'm like yeah i
guess that makes sense
technically it makes sense it's just
like the the scale of attack on titan is
very strange
maybe i should do a video on that
apparently attack on titan's the number
one tv show in the world right now
wow good it deserves to be absolutely
it's it's better than game of thrones
oh come on guys i like everything's
better than game of thrones at this
point
game of thrones is great game of thrones
is great and then
hey we got some star wars stuff coming
up in our future let's worry about that
yeah oh boy
and then uh yeah then then they didn't
and then one of them wrote gemini man
also uh
i forget which one i think david binioff
wrote
uh the wolverine movie back in the day
with ryan reynolds wolverine origins
yeah x-men origins origins colon
wolverine
when i was 12 years old and i loved it
really that was the first time i asked
for my money but you must have been a
little younger
he came out before that yeah i was in
college when it came out
goddamn i don't know how we keep talking
about our age difference accidentally
but anyway
um yeah so
hey guess what it's that time of the
episode again because this episode is
brought to you by storyblocks
storyblocks is a complete stock solution
they have an
unlimited library they've got like over
a million different video clips that you
can download they've also got
project files for both after effects and
premiere like you can actually get real
templates to use in your videos
i legitimately love this website because
it's a great way to like
fill out your video pad it out with high
quality footage
that you don't have to go out and shoot
someone already did it if you're serious
about making content like you've got to
have
story blocks in your arsenal it just
makes everything so easy it's so
affordable and hey if you work with a
group of people there are options
for enterprise licensing so you can get
everyone on the same account and
download as much as you want so if
you're interested in learning more about
this all you got to do is click the link
in the description or go to
storyblocks.com
corridorcast to find out more
information about storyblocks yeah so uh
back to this podcast what are we talking
about guys
[Music]
guys
i've got a question about all this
unreal
virtual production rendering unity
stuff uh all the all the deep stuff okay
here here's the deep question
uh what are you guys gonna try to make
this look real because there's always
this disconnect no
with with video games with with any
video game
in game like sequence cinematic cut
cutaway it's like yeah this is cool but
i know i'm in a video game
yeah 100 we are not going to try to make
it look real we're going to
see that uncanny valley from miles away
and be like let's not go to the bottom
of that
yeah so how do we so how do we lean into
that
and and like embrace the fact that it's
not gonna look real
it's it's it's just it's just a video
game you know when you're playing a
video game
you're not expecting it to be like
movie level rendering and quality and
whatnot because the amount of effort it
takes to go from that that video game
quality to
you know freaking uh what's her name
from blade runner 2049
is like immense you know that's a huge
jump
but in order to get it to like like all
you guys faces like your your
accurate portrayals of yourself from
character creator look pretty dang good
yeah like and also sorry but they're not
like photo real they're not like wow
that's a
photo realistic render it's just like
wow that's clinton a video game
cool uh same thing anytime you see like
a celebrity like what's his face in in
uh death stranding from reedus yeah
norman
norman reads uh in death training you're
like wow that's norman reedus that's
that's pretty sweet he's in my video
game but you're not like that's a photo
real thing i don't know
i don't think it's a problem it also
just works because we're making
the project we're working on is like set
in a video game
so any jank we have with unreal works
contextually within the story
yeah and you know at the end of the day
just your characters have to be
expressive that to be able to emote
you know if you can't read the emotions
and that's the problem with a lot of
games that try to go to that like photo
real thing or like where it's two motion
captured
like where you're doing a motion capture
performance and not a motion capture
puppeteering
is that you end up with pretty flat
expressions that you know could be
better and could be bigger and it's just
you know mouse opening and eyebrows
raising up and down and like
you gotta be able to push it so you can
read emotions because once again at the
end of the day it's puppets
you know show me a smiley face show me a
frowny face show me angry eyebrows
so are you saying that it's gonna lack
it's gonna necessarily lack
dramatics or no what i'm saying is that
when we're designing these characters
we're we're not trying to make them look
real we're trying to make them
expressive expressive comes like is way
higher priority versus
making it not real but also real quick
when you say what we're doing right like
are you talking about the squidward
thing right now i guess i was
like i was just bleeding into local zero
and we've got the squidward
squidward's impressive purely
entertainment it's purely for the
entertainment factor because it's
gosh darn entertaining be able to be
like this is clint with massive chin
yeah it's always a huge plastic it's
also a learning part part of the
learning process too
it's very much so that all a lot of our
videos here are just like basically us
trying to
uh rationalize time spent learning
or not rationalize but like whatever the
words utilize yeah
a little bit of rationalize you know
it's like hey i'm trying to learn how to
do this thing might as well make a video
about it
and then justify thank you thank you
yeah
yeah one of the interesting things about
doing the squidward thing is that
you know so you first you start off at
the base of the person's face
and like actually studying someone's
face as like an object to replicate in
3d
is tricky because like there's a lot of
shortcuts in your mind when you look at
somebody's face that you forget about
like you know a representation of an i
like when you just when you draw an eye
is pretty different than when i
actually looks like like for example if
somebody tried to draw an eye
you know okay they do like an almond
shape and they draw like the iris and
the pupil in the center
maybe a little bit shading call it a day
most people wouldn't do
is actually shade the white parts of
your eye they probably the white parts
of your eye white but your the white
parts of your eye actually have a bunch
of shading in them they're not white
there's a bunch of red and there's a
bunch of shadow that falls in it from
unless you're in a youtube thumbnail on
corridor digital
yeah those are the widest sizes your
eyes white and then drop the opacity
but that's more like that's an example
of like in your mind you think the white
of an eye is white
in reality it's not yeah and you have to
study
reality uh in an objective way which is
tricky so like you know
i was working on clint's face and after
i kind of did my initial pass it's like
i need to actually go and look at
clint's face and objectively study it
and see like
where do the like the planes sit where
do the the creases sit where do the
angles sit how do they line up with each
other
and those are things that you think you
know but you don't actually know and you
have to sit down and look at them
oh yeah like clint for instance is is
modeling sam right and he's got sam like
it looks pretty good it looks like sam
you take one looking like that is sam
but there's something that i couldn't
quite put my finger on i was like why
does this still look wrong
and it's because he looks like possessed
like demonized because his eyes are
brown
or like the render of that i don't know
if clint's fixed it by now but like
his eyes were really dark like the
colored part of his eyes were like
a dark brown and it just from a glance
made it looks like
he just has the most dilated pupils of
all time and so i actually went to the
other room and i was like sam look me in
the eye
and he did and i was like can we do it
and so then i came back
and uh i so i told clint i was like his
eyes are much closer to amber they're
almost like
orange in color they're very light brown
and
it's that that color contrast that
really makes his eyes stand out
and i'm i'm fairly certain if if clint
just like changed the color to more of
an orange than a brown
like lighten it up quite a bit it would
instantly look way more like sam
mm-hmm can we do like a cutaway of
each of you guys like in an intimate
setting like examining each other's
faces
very closely with like romantic music
i'm on my computer and like nico comes
walking into the room and uh
clint and dean are like talking to
griffin and nick or sorry nico like taps
clint and he's like
i need to look at your face
also before we continue we are talking
about a video that's coming out this
sunday on the corridor crew channel
and today is thursday for you guys
watching this
the day this episode drops on the
quarterback unless you're watching this
live because technically today is
tuesday
so 16 people have randomly clicked or
gone to
corridor digital.com live and found this
peter did you tweet this
i just sent it to my girlfriend wait did
you remember yeah it's her and all of
her friends or something
yes i'm sure she's sending it out to all
of her friends
but this i guess what i'm getting at is
we are talking about something that
hasn't come out yet and this is the
third time we've done that we did that
with uh
harry potter rated r we did it with the
luke skywalker deep fake thing
and there's every time there's comments
being like you guys should put this out
after it comes out we don't know what
you're talking about i'm like
well i mean you're not wrong but we're
doing this
intentionally this is like you know if
you haven't noticed we've been doing
that for like the last few weeks is
where we talk about what's upcoming but
that's because
that's for the troutons so that they
know
what's about to what's about to drop you
know it's
it's it's always a better way to do it
it creates a
i guess it creates appreciation for the
thing that we're making when you
actually get to see it
because you know the thought processes
and the stories behind what you're
seeing
well plus we're in the middle of it
we're not reviewing past stuff like if
we were to record this next week after
the video's already been
not only finished but uploaded and we're
already seeing people's reactions to it
right now we are getting the raw
idealism of what we're trying to do here
we don't know how people are going to
react to this yet you know we don't know
what
it's going to be like it's not as
interesting i i think to look at it
retroactively it's it's it's more
interesting to talk about it and to sort
of like
take a be in the middle of it take a
moment
reflect on what where you're at when you
when you are in the middle of it
because like you said niko then the
outcome
is maybe not the same as you
had expected but you can appreciate that
a little bit more because it's you know
yeah yeah yeah this is like this is like
getting the
like the tour tape when you go to like a
tourist location audio guide this is the
audio guide this is the extra
experience for me to stop in
at each stop yeah it's just like it
feels really novel to me and i don't
think anyone else is ever really
doing something like this or at least i
don't know of any examples like that
there's always like
you know director's commentary the
product's all done and now you have the
people who made it talk about it and
that's like a very commonly like
walked upon uh thing right a lot of
people have done that we've done that
for years
uh anytime we've we've talked about
something we did on the podcast uh
i don't know i find it really
interesting to be talking about it
before anyone else has seen it while
we're still we're
before we even done with it yeah all the
thoughts are still swimming around yeah
you got stuff that comes right off the
cuff
so i i kind of like it so i know i i'm
sorry that we're talking about stuff
that you won't be able to see for
another few days but
hey it's a hype piece
yeah uh so
i think i'll go ahead nico
[Laughter]
well i was gonna say this ties in a
little bit to also some of the stuff
like uh we plan to do on son of a
dungeon
um yeah we are creating these 3d
environments
and hopefully i mean we see this
other thing we have no idea if this math
is all going to work out there's
there's some hair brained theory right
now that we can capture
tracking data and then have it natively
live in an iphone
that then you can record into an iphone
have it capture tracking data from that
you gave it from after effects and then
put that footage back into after effects
and have
the new footage just naturally track to
the scene
um so so that's a whole another
like side it's not exactly the same
thing as you guys are doing today but it
also utilizes a completely 3d
environment
and it's a and it's a totally new way to
think about a 3d environment
yep we have not even so many things are
going to go wrong
i i don't i don't even know yeah i mean
yeah that's true but what it really
comes down to right now is that we
need to figure out a way to produce a
lot of content
a lot of digital content and you know
traditionally
for us it's like all right you plan your
shot and if it's going to be an entirely
cg scene you just have peter spending
you know
three months working every day trying to
get a spider-man short film
done uh or those animations though peter
those animations man
but my point is that like it takes a lot
of brute force effort
and for son of a dungeon you know we
have
an eight hour campaign i mean i don't
know how long it is eight episode
campaign
half of it's filmed already and we're
going to be going through and reenacting
scenes for moments from the game play uh
you know as if we're actually in the the
game itself like
that's we could we could do that the
traditional way you film us on a green
screen you
uh do all the effects and whatnot but
it's like we're talking hundreds of
shots
we've got to figure out a way to
streamline that as efficiently as
possible
and so that's what we're trying to do
right now because
you don't the first thing that comes to
my mind is
streamlining all this stuff is that it's
just going to look bad it's like
we also don't want that so it's i think
it's a lot of our effort right now is
trying to figure out the best way to
kind of like
find the right balance between doing
something very good looking but also
making it really easy to be able to just
all right this is the moment i just want
you to look around me like oh yeah i
just fell off of a cliff and now i'm
climbing back up
and it's like all right dude you do it
and he's like oh final product done
cool next next one we've got if you're
concerned about it having to look
real like well not really i'm saying
look good there's a difference between
looking good and looking real
yeah that's true that's true i i i guess
like yeah having it look good is is a
big deal
um we do want that uh
but people people for people will
forgive people will forgive us
if it doesn't look like uh you know lord
of the rings
oh you should like yeah i don't think
we're even trying
to make it look like ltr but just like
being in that little world with like
the music playing and like especially
when we first
show some of those shots like the first
few shots that we show
of us in the mini world you know we have
to do some sort of camera trick and then
the
the actors like as we're walking along
we need to like look up and be like oh
oh hey you know as if you just shrunk
down with us and now
we're we're realizing how small we are
like little
little tricks like that to help you know
like ease people into it and then once
once that happens i think we can kind of
do whatever once people get
get understanding of how that format is
functioning
so these animations are you guys going
to be in characters
in character as your dnd characters in
these animations
well yeah we're going to be filmed on a
green screen right but the idea is that
the camera
tracking is done at the same time as the
footage is being recorded so we don't
have to go back and like
camera track every single shot because
it's like it's not that hard to throw a
green screen effect on a shot it's like
all right you
pick your color and done you know you
might require a little bit of polishing
but
the camera tracking is the hardest part
in that story yeah so it's like
and then just ideally you get a
background that's just ready to go you
can literally just drop it in
render it and you're good to go that's
the idea yeah so
i mean with some of a dungeon the the
trick that we're doing for this whole
thing
is two tricks one is that we are using
photogrammetry to rebuild the
sets in 3d so which is super cool it's
super cool it looks awesome
so sam and spencer after we do a game
take a bunch of pictures of the game
board which is all using dwarven forged
miniatures
and basically with all these pictures
you can replicate the game board
as a 3d model with textures so we have a
fully realized
3d set landscape with you know taverns
and
walkways and caverns and fields and
trees and like all this stuff would take
you
days and days and days and days to put
together and we don't have to do any of
that
it's just take pictures and you're done
so trick number one trick number two
is that we are then using a program for
the phone called cam track ar which is
made by the guys
at fx home i love those guys yeah me too
i mean that's how we got our start
and uh and so cam track ar is using
apple's ar kit
api to basically give you a real-time
motion tracked camera
as a either an after effects file or
potentially an fbx i think they're
working on that right now
alongside your video so you record the
shot on your phone
you don't need tracking markers or
anything like that and when you're done
the shot
is saving a little folder alongside like
an fbx file that contains the
like a 3d replication of your camera's
motion so you can grab that
pop it onto your computer in after
effects or in cinema 4d or whatever
and your footage lines up with your
virtual camera instantly you don't have
to do
any afternoon connection it's super
amazing there's a couple limitations in
that
cam track ar is stuck using your phone's
image buffer which is different than the
quality of the video you get or the
pictures you get when you
actually take that's not their fault to
be clear that's that's apple's fault
it's limitation apple is placed on their
whole ar
platform yes and it's something that you
know they are
increasing the quality of that as the
phone's hardware
you know gets better and better over
time but it's one of the things that you
know they have to think about how this
affects all their phones so like it's a
you know it's a gradual rollout things
don't happen instantly yeah um but it's
going to get better
yeah it'll get better before you know it
i'm hoping that a couple of guys at
apple or gals at apple are listening to
the podcast or watching the channel
they're like
you know maybe we should just bump up
the quality a little bit i mean please
do it do it
let us use the 4k video i can't wait
until this technology is available in
actual
film cameras that's never going to
happen no i wouldn't say that either
that's never going to happen cameras no
not
i actually don't think it's really going
to happen too much with digital cameras
because i think
i think phones are just going to become
the digital camera of the future
i think it's like i think that's a
reasonable argument i hope it's not the
case but
yeah it's only a matter like give it 10
years and like the whole like oh i need
to use my
you know full-frame sony camera to get
depth of field like no you
your phone's depth sensor combined with
this ai is going to give you whatever
focus
you want to do at any point in time
before or after you get the shot along
with your real-time
tracked camera along with all your other
settings that are you know
fantastic real-time like high-quality
bokeh
like i mean there's a header 1.8 on my
little tiny sensor like
yeah there's gonna be uh
like high-end use cases for cinema
cameras
but yeah but no one's like you're not
gonna go out of their way to make
those features for high-end cinema
cameras because they're one-time use
cases you know that's something like go
and get your vive trackers and
make your own program like right no
one's going to sit there and make the ar
kit
for panavision's you know two hundred
thousand dollar cinema camera
and the average the average digital
creator is
gonna go to go more into that i could
see black magic doing it
i can see them implementing in like the
the pocket 8k camera that'll be
announced next year that's also pure
speculation i made that up uh
you know like they just have a feature
like oh yeah it also uh live tracks um
your scene what really because it's like
fancy cameras these days are basically
phones too
yeah you know what they need to
everybody needs to get on is getting
like the gopro style
stabilization into your camera like i
would love black magic because sony has
it for their a7 cameras
when you when you edit the videos in
sony's like proprietary video editor
there's a file with each shot that you
can drop in there and now you just have
a slider to stabilize your shot because
it has all the imu data attached to it
wow uh which is awesome so all the bumps
and jitters and things like that you
don't need to use like warp stabilizer
there's literally just a feature now
in the those programs you can turn on
i'd love it if blackmagic had that in
their cameras wait what is
sony's editing software called i like
imaging
vegas something like that vegas that's
what i was looking for
i don't think nico's talking about vegas
though no um but what you're talking
about has been done for years in
in gopros using a program called real
study which was designed by a dude
i think his name is robert mcintosh he
lives like in
in santa monica like and he sold it to
gopro so he doesn't technically own it
anymore but like
it basically did that exact thing gopros
have imus in it uh initial
inertial measurement units uh to
basically measure the rotation of a
thing so it knows
when the camera like tilts down it
doesn't have to read the image
like warp stabilizer does to know that
it's like tilting down
to counteract that and it's the same
thing that the insta360 cameras have
yeah which is a game changer for
insta360 camera absolutely
and but yeah so it's like it's basically
a way to like get really accurate
stabilization for a camera but it has to
happen at the hardware level
and you know red had imus in it
that can like the red epic or even the
red one i don't know uh
yeah and no one ever did anything with
it it was the biggest disappointment
those cameras for me that's surprising
one of the issues is that uh it needs to
be adjusted based on the lenses you're
using
so your image stabilization is different
for each lens that is true that actually
is probably the biggest reason why they
then it was probably not an imu that was
fast enough to like give you
uh a frame by frame accurate
representation of motion
user like a thousand frames per second
red zeimu was used mainly for just
telling if you're shooting portrait
versus
landscape yeah fair enough
yeah but most of the imus are like
operate at like a thousand hertz
yeah or more and that it's been that way
for a long time how do they work
imus yeah well you got i'm just assuming
you know
there's there's three different types of
imes you got your accelerometer you got
your gyroscope and the magnetometer or
magnetometer the accelerometer and the
magnometer are going out of control red
fix it uh magnometer
magnometer magnetometer fancy word for a
compass
it's a compass um it's basically able to
uh
uh absolute orientation uh a gyro is
able to
very accurately measure rotation what
not an accelerometer is able to measure
uh acceleration so if you're going at a
constant speed it's going to read zero
but if you start accelerating like
speeding up it's going to give you a
measurement and from that you can
actually
uh derive a whole bunch of like pretty
accurate info from it
it can be noisy to have to throw filters
on and that's why i use all three to
kind of like have
it's like the checks and balances system
in a government so
when you get one dictator taking over
the magnetometer suddenly it's like it
starts going in the wrong direction
um you know i think those rococo suits
have
magnetometer magnet magnometers
magnetometer magnetospheres have
magnetometers in them because i i was
working with my rococo suit in san
francisco
i came down to l.a it stopped working i
was like why isn't my suit working
talk to the support people or whatever
they were like did you change the city
your home i was like no i changed it to
la it started working because it was
based on the magnetic fields
on the planet it's crazy i mean yeah
it's
that that is actually pretty crazy i
didn't realize that would it would have
that kind of effect but
i don't i have very little experience
working with the number of sensors that
you'd have in a motion capture suit
do you think earth's magnetic pole is
going to flip within our lifetime i hope
not what
is that dude the last time it happened
it led to like a massive extinction
event
did or 50 000 it ago i wouldn't say
massive but it did lead to a
big bit of an ecological disaster
because it's in the process of doing it
kind of yeah but the process goes on for
like 100 000 years doesn't it
no no no it's uh shorter it's it's much
shorter
but okay i don't know i don't know the
exact time frame i don't know if we're
talking like over the course of a year
or over the course of like a day over
the course of a decade i'm not exactly
sure but definitely less than like
a hundred thousand years one thing i'm
really hoping to see like before i die
is a star going supernova me too i mean
beetlejuice
is our closest uh uh example but
that could be it's literally on death's
doorstep right now beetlejuice is set to
explode any minute but any minute in
astrophysics terms might be now or in
ten thousand years
is that going to have any effect pretty
much no it won't
you'll we'll be able to see it but it
won't actually affect us like
the rays are too far away to actually
like harm us
but it will be super bright it will be
brighter than the full moon
whoa yeah just imagine just a star
that's so bright it's like the full moon
it looks like it will never get dark
that'd be so cool
yeah it's been amazing i'd love to see
it yeah
how long would that last for about about
a couple months it'd be like
yeah yeah world it'd be nuts that was
super cool but
who knows when that will happen we'll
never know until it's happening isn't
there a theory that the
the star of bethlehem was a supernova
well
that is the star of bethlehem what is
that in the jesus story the christmas
you don't know what the star of
bethlehem is
no i didn't that's the star that was
over jesus during his birth
it's part of the nativity nativity
legend
the lore oh i see what you're saying no
i have heard of that
i have heard of that yeah i have heard
it i
don't know i don't know yeah there's
jesus here there's the
eyes and they saw a star and it was in
the star and then they followed it and
then it led them to where jesus was that
whole thing
did my other my favorite like ancient
history conspiracy theory is that the
dark ages were triggered by a meteor
impact
we would have evidence of that if that's
cause though we would definitely have
evidence they have some evidence but
yeah i don't have any evidence
[Laughter]
dark ages were the result of just like
an extreme economic collapse
the dark ages are the time after the
roman empire phil yeah okay so the roman
empire was you know we had
roads and we had books and we had
libraries you know all that kind of
stuff
and then then nothing until the
renaissance well
it's a bit of middle ages like you know
around the thousands yeah but the middle
ages didn't really start until like
yeah a thousand nine hundred around
there yeah 900 years
where i mean once again it's not like
there was nothing but where we had the
dark ages and the thing
the thing that actually happened or my
understanding is that we basically went
through a cold snap
um and it was almost like a mini not a
mini ice age but you know a severe
climate change
yeah um which is actually what pushed a
lot of the people down into
the roman empire from the northern
regions interesting all right which led
to that yeah
there's there's a lot go that's like a
super r
like casual overview yeah you know
nico's casual history moment right here
thank you you troutons for tuning in to
corridors hardcore history
okay guys i got this one i'm a history
buff okay are you ready peter i'm so
ready
all right so the roman empire right uh
you know
great soup it didn't actually become an
empire
until well not until augustus really
caesar sort of started the whole thing
but then
you know roman empire starts to fizzle
out you know 300 400
500 a.d they got sacked a bunch of times
it didn't just collapse all at once so
there was like a 300 year period where
its influence kind of like cleft
right yeah collapsed and then after that
not only was there
a weather thing going on but it also
refers to like
humanity's knowledge base
dark dark as in like not like the light
of
the the luminescence of knowledge and of
humans
transferring information from one to the
other so that like
civilization might be built had gone
dark
and then the middle ages the medieval
times
you know are just the mid the middle
point between then and now
um and then the renaissance means the
rebirth
which is the the rebirth of knowledge
and science and
and information gathering and sharing so
why is hearing this
right now so much more interesting than
when i was hearing it in school
years ago yeah the same thing man
saves me i think the school system is
fundamentally flawed
at a fundamental level like obviously i
think school is good and i think
teachers are great i'm just saying like
how school like works in general
yeah is it can has a lot of areas to be
improved but those improvements would be
like
fundamentally different so it's like
it's not even really worth talking about
if you're trying to be productive
yeah i mean it works great for some
people but everybody's so different you
know
what works for one person is not going
to work for me because it didn't and i
i skated my way through
yeah most people don't don't don't find
interest in something until
like they realize like what knowing
something about it
how that improves themself
you know like we're all self-interested
in that way like
you're not going to care about something
unless you understand
how it localizes to you yeah um
in general why do i have to learn
trigonometry i'm never going to use this
yeah well that's always the thing when
you're in high school it's like
why do i have to learn this i'm never
going to use it this is stupid man
i've been having to use trig recently
and i'm like why didn't i take this in
high school
i love trigonometry actually it triggs
great
yeah ren's been helping me wasn't have i
a little bit okay cool i've totally been
helping peter you need my help
you know i found trigonometry helped me
the most when i played pool
or yeah because it's all like i mean
that's a little bit more geometry yeah
it's not trigonometry but
it's just my really shallow
understanding of trigonometry
trying to apply it to something in my
own life and i mean totally i mean
yeah absolutely that's applicable right
there i found trigonometry be like the
last math subject that was like
relatively easy to
grasp i mean it's still complicated but
like
the process of solving trigonometry was
relatively straightforward
because then calculus came after that
that wasn't straightforward anymore
oh no i never had to take calculus
me neither i took calculus four damn
whoa
i took uh two levels of calculus in
college also so how
and then calc three and four is not even
called calculus anymore it's just called
like uh
differential equations and vector
calculus and then there's linear algebra
yeah gross my buddy that i went to
uh undergrad with uh ended up getting a
graduate phd in math
applications and then now he works at
deloitte
like when they when they need to
understand
like if there's a if there's an
international business merger
happening between like one company and
another and they have like all these
different like assets in this in all
these different
types of money and assets across the
globe
they basically are like hey uh i won't
mention his name but they're like hey
i'll just call him bill they're like
bill
uh we you need to figure out um
like how we're gonna do this and whether
or not it's gonna be profitable
whoa and he'll take all those
applications of like what a currency is
sitting at and they have this much in
this form of currency and have this much
in this form of currency and this much
in this real estate market in this
country
and if you take it all and you put it
over here or you turn it into this
currency for like
a week or a year then you'll get this
back and like
all this insane like super high level
global corporate stuff it's it's wild
man
yeah yeah so anyways
uh made all of us look like squidward
and it was fun
[Laughter]
but like you're kind of talking a little
bit about uh us like trying to learn all
this stuff
um so you've gotten really into unreal
like you
hardcore fast-tracked your your unreal
knowledge over the last few months
yeah like you're making a freaking video
game i'm still making a video
and of course sam uh has been like he's
sam's
always doing his own thing just off by
himself doing his own thing and he spent
the whole like last year
uh learning unreal because he was kind
of playing around with unity at the
beginning of 2020 and
i will take credit for this i convinced
him to go to unreal oh really
why is that just because it seemed more
applicable to stuff that we were doing
stuff that we could do uh matt workman
uh cinematography db i think yeah
cinematography database
uh is yes database yes uh you know he
was he's been doing all that stuff and i
was like you know what sam you should
really do that and like
obviously it's all sam's decision and he
put in all the hard work but i kind of
like nudged him in that direction
anyway my point is uh uh concepts by ren
weikman
yes and niko has also been like getting
really into unreal lately
and i i was like man these guys have
gotten in all
all unreal and i know at the end of
december i was like i'm gonna get into
unreal too
but i've changed that out yeah
sorry i'm just waiting for unreal three
dude unreal five four point two six the
preview
yeah that's right we actually are the
preview of unreal five is supposed to
drop this year
oh maybe yeah i'm not gonna go into that
yet
you should continue my point is that
i've decided to learn houdini instead of
unreal
because i feel like that would best
complement your guys's
experience and knowledge of unreal so
that if i think that'd be awesome
yeah um yeah
unreal is cool and all and i do want to
learn it at some point i do think it is
critical to the future of a lot of stuff
that i want to do
but you know i only have so much time in
the year to like
learn new things because learning stuff
is hard especially hard stuff
can you explain friend how those two are
complementary for the layman
yeah so basically houdini asking asking
for a friend
i swear houdini is really
in a really advanced 3d package it's not
so much good at like
modeling things but it's good at
building systems
okay and houdini's like
it seems like magic hence the name you
know the famous magician houdini
uh so it's really good at being able to
build procedurally generated
objects and what i mean by that let's
say you want to
you want to build a building uh you in
in cinema 4d you would basically model
you know the foundation the building
itself you then go in and model all the
different windows and maybe like the
molding around them windows and the
bricks and all that stuff but in c4d
sorry and houdini instead of doing all
that manual stuff because once you
once you've made that in cinema 4d you
have a model and
your your ability to change that is kind
of limited whereas in houdini then you
can go through
and rather in houdini you basically
build it out
with parameters instead you're like all
right i want this to be
basically you're building everything
with sliders so that that way once
you've made your thing
you've built out your building now you
can actually change it you can make it
be twice as
tall but have it correlate out to the
number of floors the floors
sizes are always the same you could
change the size of the window you could
randomize everything
so then like once you put in all this
effort to build this one building
suddenly you can have
a city every building is different and
it's a slightly different ways or
extreme ways so
then you can the reason why that works
with unreal is that you can
port it over to unreal if you want to
make a game or something and you just
want to randomly
procedurally generate a level yeah you
put in all the work to
uh basically build out your parameters
for
your whatever you're making it could be
anything i'm using a building as an
example
and then you can use those dials in
unreal to
make it fit your scene as you want it
also
the thing that interests me more than
that is the simulation side of things
oh yeah it can simulate pretty much
anything in houdini it is the
software package of choice for all
hollywood studios for doing dynamics and
effects and stuff like that
when i say buildings exploding crumbling
fire explosions smoke in the sky
liquid pouring through everything you
can pretty much do all of that in
houdini
um and most vfx houses use that for that
damn good yeah and that also works with
uh with unreal you can
simulate your your crazy stuff like you
could have a building literally collapse
and you can uh bake that out save it out
and import that into unreal and i don't
exactly know
the specifics of how they integrate
together yet i just know that they can
well yeah so half-life alex that's what
they did for the strider scene where
every the
buildings are exploding and there's a
bunch of debris everywhere they did all
this
yeah and the plane crash train crash
train crash yeah um
all of those alembic files right
something like that i
have fallen in love with the limbic
files this year they are the future of
everything
mm-hmm yeah olympic files messing with
olympic files actually like last year
yeah they're really cool it's so easy
actually
to transfer stuff it's like no more
keyframe data and things like that just
like yeah just kick out your olympic
file
so i'm glad that some like i'm glad that
people in the industry are getting
together to like
solve these common problems they have to
do all the time like aces
is people getting together to solve like
hey we all shoot on different cameras
and we end up putting them all into the
same timeline now i have to match all
their colors and it's a pain in the butt
i have to do it every time
it's like is there a way we can fix that
yes aces and now
i don't fully understand how aces works
i know
i know what it is but like how
so there's a thing called an idt for
cameras that don't shoot in raw
so an idt is an image something
transform image data transform i think
uh basically all it is
is it's like whatever your camera's
shooting in whether you're sony or your
canon or your whatever
whatever you're shooting in there's an
idt file if the company's a pro company
and they got their stuff together
they give you there's an idt file that's
built you know built into the aces
packages
that will take that color profile and
basically invert it and remove all of
like the color data and turn it back in
just regular
basic data so you can then remap that
data into any color space that you want
so when you shoot in raw that's
basically where you're at already
um you know your raw is just numbers
it's just basically representing the
electron signals
electronic signals you're getting off
your sensor and
at some point those signals need to be
turned into an image and that's when you
process your raw and you
debayer it into an image um so something
in raw is basically
already in aces because you just go
right from the raw into an ace's color
space but there's a lot of cameras that
don't shoot in raw
but they have what's called the idt
which can then transform their color
space
into basically that completely neutral
color space which then is
aces um and then from aces you can make
it so it looks good on a tv you can make
it so it looks good on a movie projector
but every camera is
arriving at the same common starting
point so every camera looks the same
all the colors are the same all the
contrast is the same you're just
starting with every camera as if they
were all shooting the exact same color
profile
okay question so you have a 5d mark iii
that has
nowhere near the dynamic range of the
red that shoots raw
you feed this 5d footage into the aces
algorithm or whatever and it strips it
of all that color
contrast saturation data and gives you
the raw
not exactly raw but the data back
wouldn't it be like
clipping or like how does it deal with
the difference in dynamic right now i
mean
you know if the camera's clipped it'll
clip out to white you'll get
i mean you'll get the the higher
contrast to look so to speak but
it's going to be mapped so the contrast
is going to be mapped to the actual
light values
correctly so like you know something
that's twice as like if you have one
side of your space that's
uh twice as bright as the other side of
your face that will be represented
the same with the same intensity across
all the cameras okay i think i have an
analogy here let me know if this is
wrong
you know how you have like object space
and world space and 3d packages
what if you have all these different 3d
models they're all different cameras
and they're all in object space and aces
is basically like
taking each of those objects and
switching it to world space exactly so
that everyone
is going off of the same world
coordinates rather than their local
subjective coordinates that's basically
what's happening because okay
where in that are the uh lamp stands
that are
welded to the are they in there
wow okay well the funny thing is like
aces is kind of going back the same
thing that's happening in like
video game engines and rendering engines
which is
when you're doing the calculations for
light you want light to be
like linear basically if something's
going to be twice as bright as something
else
you know one's going to have a value of
one the other one should have a value of
two like
mathematically that's how things need to
work for all of your you know addition
and subtraction and multiplication to
work correctly when you're adding layers
together
and so aces is going to make sure that
whatever camera you're using
if you film something that's twice as
bright as something else in your scene
that the values are going to be twice as
high you know so they're not going to
have any weird messed up color curves or
things like that they're messing it up
so like all your calculations are going
to fit everything's going to be even
across the board and so on and so forth
because we already have log images which
are basically they look black and white
they look incredibly flat and low
contrast but it's just that's like the
camera's way of maximizing
the data retention for an image but the
problem is that all cameras
still do that differently yeah it's vlog
is like the most unscientific scientific
approach to camera imaging like
yeah there's no science and log once you
get down to it it's like every camera is
it's just everybody is screwing around
basically making low contrast
picture profiles for you to layer them
fix when you get into your computer
oh but then directors they see that log
image on the monitor and then they start
growing attached to it so then the final
video or the final movie
is very flat because they didn't really
correct it because the director liked
that look
[Laughter]
yeah that was real big back in the day
when the alexas were hitting the market
yeah
you saw a lot of flat colors yep
yep anyway so aces i know i've i
so aces is just a way to basically have
a bunch of different cameras
all looking the same in your timeline
because that's been a big problem like
you're saying it's like a colorist has
to go through and
match this camera to the next camera and
that requires him to
basically choose like a master camera to
match all the other cameras
too yeah and not only does it make all
your cameras match
it also makes all of your math correct
so when you're using like an
offset slider it's actually correctly
correctly applying the offset math
when you're going to take two layers and
add them together you're getting a
correct
addition now how is this different from
a linear workflow
it is a linear workflow never mind
[Laughter]
aces is basically a fancy way of saying
linear interesting
okay yeah okay that's i mean that's kind
of
i think that's a good like place to
maybe end it because it it sort of hits
home like
you know that aces format
and all the little things that people
uh discover along the way yeah aces
character creator
alembic like all these things yeah
they're all professionals getting
together and be like look we're all
solving the same problem
over and over let's just come up with a
way to actually make sure would you say
aces
is aces a standard yes okay
what's that stand for academy color and
coding system
cool wasn't there like a uh aces 2020 or
something like that some sort of color
standard from
the oscars or yeah that's that's aces
that exactly
the academy the film academy academy
color and coding system
okay yeah so it's it's the best of the
best guys out there who are like yeah
we've invented color grading it's like
technicolor is like
yeah you know we invented color uh you
know in your movies and pictures and tv
like that
that's us we're the ones who started
that it's like them plus all the other
people that are doing it these days
that's really cool and you know what's
really funny this is my part where i
complain about adobe
oh i'm ready all right adobe premiere
we can support all the camera formats
except for blackmagic you know the one
camera that everybody likes to use for
indies filmmaking but not them
but anyways we're all camera formats but
we also don't support aces because we
don't you know
aces in premiere they don't have aces in
premiere wait really yeah
i know isn't that messed up like aces
have been out for like four years now
i wonder if that's like is it because
black magic uh da vinci is a competitor
and they're like no cause aces isn't uh
black magic sure sure but like
no i mean okay that kind of destroys my
argument a little bit but i like because
i feel like they're kind of like a
pioneer of the aces
in turn they are i mean well i mean
movie is very spiteful to be fair
davinci resolve is the industry standard
for color grading
yeah um but i think it's more because
premiere
is built on a bunch of different legacy
systems of how to edit
and then like you know this is the thing
like when the professionals got together
like what's a simple way to do this ah
let's do it this way
then don't be like
we didn't do that yeah
my reaction is to always try to defend
adobe
i always i'm like adobe's great adobe is
great
but i'm getting tired man it's got a
special place in all of our hearts
let's be honest well it's because it's
what i use it's like i know
adobe after effects very well i i know
adobe premiere pretty well and i could
do pretty much anything i want using
these programs and i think they're great
most of the time and yet i don't know i
do have
some complaints dude most of the time
now it's like an hour before i can start
editing in premiere
on my home computer i'm like bug fixing
for the first hour like every single
time okay i don't have that problem at
least it's so frustrating
yeah yeah adobe adobe kind of feels like
like me
where it's like i'm getting a little
older like i learned mental ray i
learned 3ds max everybody else is using
cinema 4d and now they're using blender
and now they're using unreal
i was just a 3ds max guy back in the day
like i could try to learn blender
but i'm just a freaking baby now i'm
gonna be like what makes me special if i
try learning blender now peter's way
better than i am it's gonna take me 10
years to get to where peter is
and that's premiere right now it's like
we
we did you know we did editing really
good like 15 years ago 10 years ago like
we were the guys like
when you left final cut pro 7 you came
to premiere because that's our our
workflow
and it's like oh things really changed a
lot
i think you really hit it on the head a
moment ago when you said it's built on a
lot of legacy layers
yeah that's what it comes down to in my
opinion it's like why doesn't adobe have
a better
3d system why doesn't it have a node
based system it's all still layer based
uh and and it's like we i remember
asking one of the
the product developers at nab uh in
charge of like
customer feedback and bug reporting or
whatever remember that
i asked them whenever i'm inside of
rotobrush every time i click
to draw like a little brush stroke the
entire and i let go the entire image
goes black for a second and comes back
and it's very distracting when i'm
trying to like track something where my
it's not that big of a deal i'm able to
get by and he was like yeah we can't fix
that that was literally his responses
like there's too much code
from like years past that we can't
really it would require
overhauling everything to fix that so
we're not wow
that was i'm paraphrasing but that was
basically his response i
remember i remember being there being
like are you serious
you can't fix that why wouldn't they
design
up new a new platform
and who knows i i'm i don't know how
much trouble they're having behind the
scenes to be able to like
restructure from the ground up here
right here listen listen okay
i'm gonna put my business man hat on for
a second okay
if i had a stock that was the same
x number of years ago it was like it's
it's more than doubled
okay in like the last six years adobe
stock
now they're sitting on a mountain of
cash they've got more subscribers to
their suite than ever
they probably can afford more r d right
now than ever before
why wouldn't you at at some point
just go guys like we're gonna take
we're gonna hire on new people or we're
gonna take our best veterans that we
have
and we're gonna send them all over here
to rebuild
something that's gonna be more efficient
for years to come
i think you answered your own question
when you started this it's because our
stock doubled in the past six years
they're making a bunch of money
why right but you know but you don't
need to you don't need to release
that but you need to develop it so that
way it starts going back down as
if everyone leaves you and by the way
here's a new product in all fairness
maybe they are
maybe we don't know that maybe they are
fantastic because like what they need to
do is literally just
literally start building a new effects
program from
scratch yes they need to throw away
everything that was previously used
throw it away like take the concepts but
don't use any of the code yeah it's
going to take a lot of time to rebuild a
program from scratch
but with the amount of money we're
paying them and everybody else is paying
them dude they should do it
one of the worst things as an as an
artist is when you lose your work from a
crash like you forgot to save your auto
saves weren't working and it's like wow
i just lost two hours of work
it sucks it's a it's a it's a one of the
worst feelings he's like i just lost two
hours of my life
not only that now i have to go back and
do it
again can you imagine
can you imagine if there was a sorry go
ahead go ahead and so so it's like
you're like oh this is this hurts so
much to do
and yet inevitably without fail every
single time
after you've redone it it is better
it is always better yeah because you you
you learned from like the little tiny
micro mistakes you made
kind of stumbling your way through the
process of anything you ever do
and now when you have to redo it
something like oh when i stepped on that
that tile the floor dropped out and i
fall into a dungeon i'm not going to
step on that tile and
just like that's so true not today tyle
clinton i like to call it the andrew
price method because uh when we're
on a podcast with him he was kind of
describing this like it's not bad to
redo your work because it'll always be
better
yeah totally unless you're really under
pressure and you're getting really
anxious and stressed out you're like
yeah i mean yeah yeah what were you
gonna say jake oh i was just gonna say
can you imagine if there was like a
a car company or something where like
ford's like oh well we invented the the
model a
engine so we pretty much don't need to
build another engine ever again
but we're good we got it figured we'll
add a few more bells and whistles on to
it
you know the passenger and the driver
can change the temperature independently
of each other
we invented air conditioning niko it's
done
yeah little features built on top of
that engine is like oh you only do air
conditioning
yeah yeah no they they definitely need
to do that that's just the things like
they're they're making a lot of money
and we're paying them a lot of money and
with every month that passes
and like the janky tower of jenga blocks
gets higher as they stack more and more
features like you know now you got
rotobrush 2.0 but you still have like
all the matte features from the first
one and then you maybe have roadbrush
1.0 question mark and there's like a
beta you can sign into
anyways now you have a new 3d interface
but you also have the same old 3d
interface and you have the newer filters
but also the legacy filters you have the
new title system you have the old title
system the new
title system it's actually really slow
and buggy uh but it does work better if
you take the you know two weeks to learn
it but there's also the slow one
the old one which maybe isn't slow
anymore and you know it's like
[Laughter]
you know so it's also a bummer because
it
back in the day i don't know i was using
it when i was like
14 so i don't know how much of a
grasp i had on it but it seemed very
robust like back in the day
after effects and premiere were very
good programs they still are very robust
it's just graded it's just their you
know their stacks on stacks and stacks
of different code now like
it's funny because like being an unreal
like i'm seeing that it's like okay i
want to turn lights
oh wait there's four different versions
of lights um
which box do i check that says shadows
because there's four boxes that say cast
shadows
it's like well there's the one for the
shadow method from ten years ago there's
one from the shadow method five years
ago that one
two years ago you know it's like that's
true yeah
but i think unreal and you know epic
like i think they're really
like it's obviously still kind of an
issue but i think they're really on top
of that because that's the name of the
game when it comes to game design
you know like they have to be constantly
like working that system and updating it
and making sure all the legacy systems
flow together whereas adobe not so
on top of it you know they don't have to
make sure all those systems flow
together quite as well they just kind of
stack them on top of each other
and i also know you know they're going
to release the new unreal might fix all
those problems yeah well new unreal is
literally it's just
the new unreal literally has a lighting
engine where it's like you just put your
lights in and that's all you do
and it has a model engine like you just
import your high-res zbrush model so you
don't do normal like there's no normal
maps
in the new unreal coming out i mean you
can but you don't have to you can you
don't have to like you just import your
model
that has all the detail and it's like
it's cool take it from here and then
they do all the rest of the optimization
behind the scenes
once again it's the same thing as aces
the same thing as alembic it's a bunch
of professionals getting together be
like look
every time i make a 3d model i sit there
and do file export and i'm making
[ __ ] normal map and i make a freaking
bump map and like it's like yeah you
don't worry don't worry don't do that
anymore like everybody's doing it you
don't have to do anymore we'll just do
it for you
now in a standardized way it is going to
mean that all of our games are going to
start being like 2 or three hundred
megabytes a piece that's gonna be the
worst
yeah gigabytes
multiply what i just said by a thousand
do you have
it's 200 megabit game man dude that'd be
awesome
granted by the time that started i mean
we really got to stop thinking about
like huge numbers like that as a problem
because it's like by the time we're
starting to see common like
games in the hundreds of megabytes god
dang it hundreds of gigabytes
we're gonna have like commonly like oh
yeah my my hard drive is 20 terabytes
yeah but deal our internet speed is
going to be like 100
gigabit like you know whatever i just
make 100 megabits
because let me think about like games
these days like 60 gigs that's
common like most games i feel like these
days are like 60 gig games they're gonna
150
go go back eight years ago and tell you
tell your eight year
younger self that like oh yeah all games
are gonna be 60 gigabytes
your mind would be blown you're like
i've never seen a game or or go back to
your 19
late 90s self if you're that old and
tell yourself
that every game was 60 then
yeah that's so crazy they they were
making so much money
it's nice how much did games used to be
60 bucks 60
oh really i remember that they were
higher for n64 games yeah
legends 70 bucks and perfect dark was
like 90 bucks
yeah actually especially with steam
steam made the price of games way
cheaper but not even just
cheaper because of inflation like
actually cheaper
wow by the dollar amount yeah yeah
people used to pay 24
in the early 2000s for a brand new cd
with like 12 songs
yeah i can't imagine paying 25 bucks to
listen to somebody's songs at this point
especially if i couldn't hear him
beforehand
no yeah you couldn't hear him beforehand
you went in there and it was like oh
well it's this artist
so it's probably good here's 20 bucks
let's [ __ ] out i can't imagine paying
for music period right now i mean i do
because i pay for spotify but like
i don't connect that with the music yeah
in my head
it's like oh it's the song i'll listen
to it i don't ever think about
the idea of a transaction having to
occur before i listen to a song
which is amazing to to like have that be
the reality uh spotify is amazing
yeah it's great they changed the game
for sure their algorithm is
algorithm is spot on is it yeah is it
that for me
i use their discovery weekly every week
and sometimes you know you get an off
week but most weeks i'm like
there's at least five bangers in here i
i agree with you
every now and then i'll throw on like
the discover weekly stuff and i'll
always end up adding a few songs to my
liked
and it's like it's it's like maybe 10
maybe less maybe one percent of the
songs
but it's something always comes from i
love discover weekly don't get me wrong
and like i listen to it every week to
pick out music but if any spotify
engineers listen to this which they're
probably not but hey
you are i got a request for you maybe
you guys are thinking about this
you guys need to figure out how to get
spotify to differentiate between
foreground listening and background
listening
because background listening you know
whatever lofi beats to study and relax
too
whatever you know i was like that's why
i got in the background there's some
jazz foreground listening
metal right so when my discover weekly
comes up
it's all jazzy metal
that's not what i want did you watch
over here
did you be a jazz medal yeah
i can show you guys if you want my spot
like discovery is like 90 percent jazzy
metal and it's like this
i don't want this yeah
so you know something like you know
somebody goes and they hit play in a
song consider
like a foreground song like somebody's
actively listening you know
versus you've been playing music for the
past two hours somebody's passively
listening
and so when you're building your
discover weekly algorithmic playlist
don't assume that just because i listen
to this music for two hours that's
really what i want to be listening to
when i'm actively listening to music you
know it's like interesting there's weird
things about music habits i feel like
they could get
a little more involved and i got one
more one more thing this is my last
thing and i really should wrap up this
podcast
why the heck do these companies not let
you just play with the dang algorithm
i mean why can't you just get like look
guys just let me input five songs and
you know give me a playlist
just let me play with your algorithm let
me make playlists and discover music
all the time same on youtube take me to
an algorithm page where i can like
throw five videos at you from five
different channels and you guys make me
a playlist of cool videos
let me use your algorithm to find videos
i feel like the youtube channel
program is worse for my somebody
because it's like i remember back in the
days like you'd watch the joke was like
oh you watch one video and suddenly your
whole recommended feed is that video and
it's like
youtube's been very honest like yeah no
that that is how it works but that has
gotten more and more intense
i feel in the last year or two yeah and
oh my god the other night you can't find
good i
i accidentally left autoplay turned on
oh no and so i fell asleep
and i had one video uh
suddenly like i started watching every
single smarter every day video
oh no six straight hours i love destiny
i think he's an amazing creator i love
his videos
but now youtube thinks that i just sat
down and watched six straight
hours of his videos in one go so now
suddenly every single video in my
recommended feed is
destined from smarter every day i love
you love his content
but i i want other content in addition
to just nothing but that
yeah man and what the heck's up with
recommending me videos i already watched
it's like guys come on give me new
videos
all right that's an issue all right well
we haven't fixed that one yet but
there's people helping people out there
so uh you know i think that's that's the
end of this one guys
um i guess i'll play us out play us out
jake thanks for listening everybody
thanks thanks for listening
quarterdigital.com better place to find
us than youtube
all right how many live viewers do have
right now
[Music]
hi 27 live viewers thanks for watching
us thanks guys
oh wait how what was the song i was
gonna play oh here we go
[Music]
it's an old garth brooks song it's like
uh
competition's getting younger
like i know the song
suck it recall this is weird
to what we were talking about come on i
should be able to do this better i've
been playing this song all week trying
to learn it but uh you know what i'm
just going to improvise okay ready
guys that was a good one
i'm sad that we didn't solve all the
problems
in the technological industries maybe
next time
or maybe the time after that if we keep
at it maybe the time after that
i don't know but we gotta go
we gotta go we gotta go
thanks for listening everyone and we'll
see you next week